the goal is to get you to your
destination as quickly as possible if
I'm taking a road trip back home I'll
just tell navigate to Aspen Colorado
it'll find the superchargers I need to
stop at along the Route take me along
I-80 through Salt Lake City to Colorado
it tells us because we're at a charger
that we need to charge for five more
minutes in order to continue the trip
every single car is doing its own air
traffic control calculation the
superchargers themselves are always
reporting information up to Tesla with
that information we know how full a
particular site is and if there are
people waiting at the site and we'll
automatically route you through church
stations with less congestion once the
car knows the route the car UI knows all
the information about the route the
initial battery pack temperature
forecasted wind speed and direction so
that we can more accurately predict your
energy consumption and what the
algorithm behind the scenes is doing is
helping you to arrive at fairly low
state of charge and then charge just
enough to get to the next charger that
it's selected with trip planner we've
solved range anxiety
[Music]